et pour
le gouvernement français durci sa
position vis-à-vis de l'afrique du sud
il rappelle son ambassadeur et suspend
tous - aux investissements
manifestations violentes des
sidérurgistes du nid métal à
trith-saint-léger l'inquiétude demeure
malgré les assurances du ministère de
l'industrie
enlèvement d'enfant par leurs pairs
étrangers
un phénomène qui prend de l'ampleur 300
cas recensés avec l'algérie une jeune
rouennaise a peut-être fait un an de
prison pour rien elle est accusée d'un
meurtre qu'un autre aujourd'hui
reconnaît avoir commis mesdames
messieurs bonsoir l'actualité de cette
fin de mois de juillet est toujours
marqué par ce qui se passe en afrique du
sud depuis l'instauration de l'état
d'urgence dimanche dernier près de sept
cents opposants au régime de pretoria
ont été arrêtés les rafles qui ont lieu
tous les jours n'arrête pas les
violences et la situation ne cesse de
s'aggraver
mémona hintermann une impression de déjà
vu et pourtant ces images sont ouverts
les obsède avec tonnes non loin de
johannesburg ce matin de noir tués au
cours d'affrontements avec les forces de
sécurité des obsèques politique
le dessin est traitée en marty il est
mort au nom de la liberté
de la paix qui concerne chacun de nous
use elle pour laquelle se bat
l'or noir métis week nous ne pouvons
connaître la paix dans ce pays tant qu
un homme le chef de l'état et puis un
beau talent continue à prendre seul
édifice
parallèlement les autorités religieuses
tente de calmer les esprits
aussi demandent maintenant quelle sera
la portée de la menace de mons elio tout
fait hier le prix nobel de la paix qui
disait si les violences des noix contre
les noirs accusés de traîtrise continue
je quitte le pays avec ma famille
quatre jours après la proclamation de
l'état d'urgence une quinzaine benoît
ont été tués par la police ou l'armée
preuve que la population ne se laissent
guère intimidé surtout les jeunes
les troubles continuent y compris dans
les zones non concernés par l'état
d'urgence à daverton une personne a été
tuée et deux autres blessées très
sérieusement par les forces de sécurité
à new york le conseil de sécurité des
nations unies va se réunir dès demain
pour examiner la situation et cela à la
demande de la france
cette demande a été formulée cet après
midi par le premier ministre laurent
fabius a noté que georges marchais avait
également fait cette demande
elle faisait partie d'une série de
mesures prises aujourd'hui par le
gouvernement français à l'encontre de
l'afrique du sud la france décide de
rappeler aujourd'hui même son
ambassadeur en afrique du sud
deuxièmement la france saisit dès
aujourd'hui le conseil de sécurité de
l'onu d'un projet de résolution
condamnant les pratiques de l'afrique du
sud et proposant une série de mesures
précises à la communauté internationale
troisièmement
tout nouvel investissement français en
afrique du sud dans quelques domaines et
sous quelques conditions que ce soit est
immédiatement suspendu mesdames et
messieurs notre pays est par tradition
une terre des droits de l'homme et des
libertés
ils ne peuvent pas sans réagir laisser
bafouer ainsi les droits fondamentaux de
la personne humaine réaction ce soir de
jean françois-poncet l'ancien ministre
des affaires étrangères de valéry
giscard d'estaing
il approuve les mesures prises par la
france mais il ajoute que le
gouvernement socialiste a réagi
peut-être avec une absence de mesures le
gouvernement britannique lui n'est pas
d'accord avec paris tout en condamnant
le régime de l'apartheid
il estime que des sanctions économiques
seraient inefficaces et n'aiderait pas
ceux qui en souffrent le plus pour bien
comprendre ce qui se passe actuellement
l'afrique du sud et pour comprendre les
réactions des capitales occidentales
il faut bien connaître les enjeux il
faut savoir surtout que ce pays possède
un sous sol très riche et que depuis
longtemps les hommes d'affaires en ont
fait leur terrain privilégié lnr ligue
jeunes
l'afrique du sud est un pays très riche
premier producteur d'or 2e de diamants
quatrième d'uranium et la liste pourrait
être encore longue puisqu'elle produit
aussi du fer du charbon et du cuir mais
ce n'est pas tout car c'est aussi un
grand pays agricole
bref l'afrique du sud c'est la première
puissance économique africaine la france
et son cinquième partenaire commercial
loin après l'allemagne les états unis le
japon et l'angleterre qui a eu 4
représentent 60% de son marché la france
seulement 3,8 pour cent
les principaux produits qu'à nous
exporte les minerais et le charbon
au total 6 milliards de francs soit 0,7
pour cent de nos importations
les principaux produits qu'elle nous
importe les machines industrielles et la
haute technologie au total 4,4 me
de francs soit 0 5 % de nos exportations
plus d'une vingtaine de firmes
françaises sont concernées
et cet embargo dérange le patronat
français serait grave parce que l'espace
à bouloire entre le terreau venir dans
les problèmes des différents pays
étrangers en particulier dans les
problèmes raciaux les problèmes
politiques qui n'est pas mon rôle je
dois dire que je souhaite ardemment en
tant que président des entreprises on
sait ce que les entreprises de notre
pays puissent continuer à travailler
mais plus que commerciaux les accords
franco sud africains sont financiers 5e
créé en ciel ce pays la france par 23 de
ses banques à financer de nombreux
projets comme par exemple une centrale
nucléaire alors un embargo
oui mais qui paiera la france
certainement mais peu car ça balance
commerciale est déficitaire avec ce pays
plus d'un milliard et demi de francs en
84 alors l'afrique du sud beaucoup plus
car elle perd un partenaire financier et
qui surtout de entraîné avec lui le
reste de la communauté européenne
a paris une manifestation a réuni ce
soir plusieurs centaines de personnes ne
devant l'ambassade d'afrique du sud
ce rassemblement était organisé par le
comité anti apartheid
il faut noter que de telles
manifestations ont lieu tous les mois à
cet endroit mais que c'est la première
fois qu'elle mobilisait autant de monde
à noter aussi que l'ambassade d'afrique
du sud se refuse à tout commentaire sur
les réactions suscitées par l'état
d'urgence en particulier celle du
gouvernement français alors jean-pierre
richard vous êtes le responsable de ce
comité anti apartheid
vous avez entendu ce qu'a dit laurent
fabius ces mesures vous par estelle
suffisante
oui c'est pas aujourd'hui que je vais
jouer les rabat joie le mouvement anti
apartheid se bat depuis dix ans pour que
le gouvernement français prenne des
mesures allant dans le sens d'un
isolement total du régime sud-africain
apartheid
je dirais peut-être en simplifiant et
pour faire bref que ce sont plus que des
paroles mais moins que des actes
ce sont des symboles on peut justement
s'interroger sur la portée réelle des
ses décisions par exemple l'interdiction
concernant les investissements peut être
contournée sur les marchés
internationaux par les bords par les
sociétés vous avez raison tout tient à
ce qu'on entend par investissements dans
le discours de laurent fabius
il n'est pas clair si les banques
françaises continueront à pouvoir
traiter avec les sociétés para étatiques
sud africaine et avec le gouvernement
sud africain
mais j'ai l'impression qu'on manque
l'opinion française se sent concerné par
ce qui se passe en afrique du sud
elles se sont concernés et souvenez vous
de la campagne contre les oranje août
cependant cet été là en 76 les chutes
la chute des importations d'orange était
de 40% et elle a mobilisé cette campagne
de vision personnes lorsque le mouvement
anti apartheid a mené une campagne
contre les prêts bancaires l'afrique du
sud
des syndicats des organisations
politiques nous ont rejoint aujourd'hui
le mouvement anti apartheid à une charte
pour isolement total du régime sud
africain en 12 points
je dirais que aujourd'hui il ya un demi
point qui a été réalisé vous parlez
d'isolement total intéressant justement
parce que il ya une question qui semble
être une question de fond on constate en
afrique du sud il y à ce que pour
appeler les jusqu'au boutistes les
jeunes par exemple qui voudrait
constituer des forteresses inexpugnable
dans l'héritage et puis il ya côté les
modérateurs les églises par exemple
alors le comité entier par tag comment
vous situez-vous
je ne sais pas si on peut dire que les
églises sont des modérateurs
les églisottes été en afrique du sud le
fer de lance de la mobilisation aussi
bien et les jeux elle veut elles veulent
dans le respect de leurs de leur foi que
la violence ne soit pas quelque chose de
systématique
surtout la violence entre
les militants anti apartheid mais en
france la population est intéressé par
le racisme aujourd'hui de badges sur moi
ils sont complémentaires
si laurent fabius dénonce le racisme en
france comment pourrait-il accepter en
afrique du sud
la durée de survie c'est à nous c'est à
nous de nous battre pour que le
gouvernement sud-africain libère nes
mandela et accepte de négocier pour que
le peuple entier d'afrique du sud soient
représentés et son mot à dire au proche
orient sans prisonniers libanais des
chiites pour la plupart ont été libérés
ce matin de la prison d'athlètes en
israël leur départ s'est déroulée dans
le calme ils ont été reconduits à la
frontière les attendaient des
responsables du mouvement chiite amal en
trois mois israël ainsi libéré plus de
900 de ces prisonniers il reste encore
environ 300 libanaise et palestiniens
détenus à apic la perspective d'une
rencontre entre les américains et une
délégation jordano-palestinienne relance
actuellement la guerre entre partisans
et adversaires du dialogue israélo arabe
côté colombes shimon peres le premier
ministre israélien qui se déclarent
prêts à négocier avec la jordanie
à condition que l'ol paie reconnaisse
israël et arrête ses activités
terroristes
côté faucon ce matin un attentat à
ankara a coûté la vie à un diplomate
jordanien jo el azara de satie premier
secrétaire de l'ambassade de jordanie en
quarts a été abattu ce matin au volant
de sa voiture l'attentât a été
revendiqué dans l'après midi par deux
organisations jihad islamique toujours
la même depuis septembre noir un groupe
anti jordanien dont le nom évoque les
massacres de palestiniens par les trop
de bureaux est saine en soixante dix un
attentat clairement ciblé qui survient
après toute une série de représailles
contre les intérêts jordanien après
l'accord dahmane septembre noah en
revendiquant l'attentât d' ailleurs
stigmatisé l'alliance hussein arafat un
avertissement évident à l'encontre des
promesses de pourparlers entre
américains et délégations jordano
palestinienne en vue d'un processus de
paix alice 17 palestiniens modérés
associé à une délégation jordanienne
est connu depuis une semaine le dialogue
est nettement plus qu'un feu vert de
washington pour louer le pédiatre à face
c'est la solution
si l'attitude américaine est positive si
la rencontre a lieu ce sera un pas
important vers la paix dans la région
sinon je crains que le radicalisme ne
l'emportent dans le monde arabe et le
monde musulman
est-ce que vous pouvez envisager donc
très rapidement de renoncer à l'option
militaire
s'il y a une attitude israélienne
favorable à une négociation sérieuse
pour aboutir à une situation de paix
dans la région
12 et abordable tout est négociable nous
ne sommes pas un peuple du tueur
nous n'aimons pas nous là pour nous
battre
côté palestinien peut-on chiffrer le
pourcentage des partisans d'une
reconnaissance d'israël
la question n'est pas de savoir combien
de palestiniens acceptent de reconnaître
israël
elle est de savoir combien de
palestiniens acceptent et val la picarde
moi je dis que 100% des palestiniens
veulent la fête à signaler que abou iyad
a rencontré ce matin le ministre de
l'intérieur français pierre joxe les
discussions entre les deux hommes ont
porté sur les problèmes liés au
terrorisme au nicaragua le principal
adversaire du gouvernement sandiniste
eden pastora a disparu depuis hier soir
il a disparu alors qu'il effectuait un
vol de reconnaissance en hélicoptère ses
partisans craignent qu'il ait été abattu
par l'armée nicaraguayenne
ce soir il affirmait que l'hélicoptère
s'était écrasé en france le ministère de
l'industrie a donné des assurances
aujourd'hui au personnel du nid métal
lusine de trith-saint-léger ne sera pas
fermée tant que des créations d'emplois
correspondant ne seront pas réalisés
manifestement ces propos n'ont pas
réussi à convaincre les sidérurgistes
qui ont manifesté parfois avec violence
claude gay nous
la colère encore marqué cette journée à
trith-saint-léger avec le saccage des
bureaux de lusine condamné cette région
du nord n'accepte pas les 200
suppressions d'emplois supplémentaires
les assurances données par edith cresson
sur le reclassement des personnels
il n'y crois pas car le gouvernement
repousse ne revient pas sur la fermeture
nous constatons que le gouvernement
renie les engagements du 24 mars 1984
c'est ta bière il entérine la fermeture
de l'usiné de tri ceci est purement
scandaleux
pour la cfdt il n'est pas question de
baisser les bras il n'est pas question
sous le manteau
la cfdt dès demain appelle l'ensemble
des travailleurs à 9h façon réfectoire
elle préconise des actions dures des
actions très dur
nous ne reculerons jeudi d'un nous ne
reculerons devant aucune forme d'action
pour obliger ce gouvernance socialiste
le gouvernement mitterrand fabius a
respecté ses engagements du 29 mars à
maintenir en totale activités ludiques
de paix demain l'agitation reprendra
syndicalistes mettent à l'eau sont
déterminés ils n'acceptent pas le
transfert de leurs activités au
luxembourg comme on a décidé les accords
au niveau européen
ils suivront avec une particulière
attention les négociations de bruxelles
où les ministres de l'industrie des dix
doivent justement parler de l'avenir de
l'acier les enlèvements d'enfants par
leurs pairs étrangers semble être une
pratique de plus en plus courante
rien que pour l'algérie 300 cas sont
actuellement officiellement recensés il
ya un an plusieurs maires ainsi privés
de leur enfant avait menacé de se rendre
à alger des promesses avaient alors été
faites et des médiateurs ont été nommés
en france et en algérie
mais devant l'absence de résultats les
mères continuent à manifester hadrons
gère mercredi ces femmes viennent offrir
un bouquet de roses à laurent fabius des
femmes divorcées dont les enfants sont
retenus en algérie des mère et une
grand-mère eve n'a pas revu ses petits
enfants depuis neuf
après les vacances avec leur père ils ne
sont pas revenus
la première année il est sympa pris avec
elle puis la deuxième il appelait sa
prière et qui laissa pu ramener à leur
ensuite ma fille elle est partie les
chercher puis rester mais l'a refusé de
lui donner la mère de ses enfants c'est
marie paule au milieu sur la photo
depuis le 17 juin elle campe avec quatre
autres femmes dans l'ambassade de france
à alger doutes sont dans le même cas
le divorce en france la garde des
enfants confiés à la mère le père qui
refuse de les rendre
l'an dernier elle avait participé à
l'opération à bateaux pour alger un
voyage symbole annulé après les
promesses des deux pays
un an après les mères se sentent floués
certes l'algérie qui se réfugiait
derrière l'absence d'un code de la
famille a depuis élaborer ce texte mais
avec deux barrages la mère qui a la
garde de l'enfant doit résider sur le
sol algérien
les jugements prononcés en france ne
sont pas exécutées en algérie rares sont
les jugements algériens qui ont accordé
d'exequatur au maire mais même si cela
était le cas le problème ne serait pas
pour autant résolu car pour sortir les
enfants du territoire algérien il faut
nécessairement une autorisation de
sortie paternel et seul le père peut la
délivrer pour sortir de ce chassé-croisé
juridique une convention bilatérale est
à l'étude cela dure depuis plus de cinq
ans son principe chaque pays
reconnaîtrait les décisions de justice
de l'autre le problème c'est que ce
texte ne serait pas rétroactif
alors pour régler les 300 dossiers en
instance paris et alger vient de nommer
deux médiateurs
l'important c'est que chaque fois que
les enfants sont en âge d'être consultés
je vais que les enfants assez tôt nous
maintenant en route un processus qui
permette de les consulter librement
souvent ce n'est pas le cas dans tautou
de l'aude avaient été ramenés quelles
pressions psychologiques d'un parent
c'est ce qu'à venir nous souhaitons nous
arriver à ce que l'enfant
chaque fois que c'est possible avec tous
tes limites que nous connaissons bien
puisque en mai m calmement et
sereinement consultés alors politique
des petits pas ou actions spectaculaires
les maires sont divisés sur la tactique
à suivre mercredi
elles reviendront à matignon premières
inculpations dans la sphère du barrage
de tesero en italie aujourd'hui l'un des
deux propriétaires de la société qui
gérait précisément ce barrage a été
arrêté il a été inculpé de catastrophes
et homicide volontaire
une jeune rouennaise a peut-être passé
un an en prison pour rien il y a deux
ans en effet elle a été accusée du
meurtre d'une personne âgée
aujourd'hui cette jeune femme est libre
mais sous contrôle judiciaire est
toujours inculpé
or ou théâtre un garçon de 15 ans vient
de s'accuser du même crime
thierry paquot c'est ici dans cet
immeuble que s'est produit le drame il
ya deux ans presque jour pour jour
les policiers y découvrait le corps
d'une femme de 71 ans frappé de
plusieurs coups de couteau
28 au total une amie du fils de la
victime marie france tu as tu sauves à
devenir rapidement le principal suspect
beaucoup de charges vont peser sur elle
une masse de témoignages des expertises
et puis aussi et peut-être surtout sa
présence dans l'appartement à leur
précisément de la mort de la vieille
dame
un ensemble de présomptions qui
finalement vont amener le juge a
prononcé l'inculpation et la détention
de marie-france d'assaut le dossier ne
sera pas pour autant refermer preuve en
laye hier l'enquêté a débouché sur
l'arrestation du jeune voisin de la
victime un mineur de 15 ans un mineur
qui avoue être le meurtrier
ceci fait qu'aujourd'hui marie-france
tatts au clame son innocence une
innocence que dit elle elle à répéter et
répéter un juge qui ne voulaient pas
l'écouter
je vous rassure acteurs est en prison
vous êtes une menteuse vous dit pas la
vérité
vous avez tout votre belle-mère et vous
voulez pas l'avouer imams salage j'ai
passé ma vie mais je dois pas encore à
100 crise ont pigé dans virée sur les
deux épaules ce sujet très bien que j'ai
la conscience tranquille je costume au
fait d'une erreur justice que vous
faites même sa mère alors mais de toute
façon j'irai jusqu'au bout de cette
histoire je veux la vérité si j' espère
que le religieux la vérité est que vous
verrez que je vous ai jamais menti dans
les marques et les lycées tous ses
débuts quand pour que justice on devrait
connaître les gens en prison comme ce 9
octobre quand quelqu'un dit qu'elle est
innocente
il devrait approfondir les aussi
regarder la faune un an de prison pour
rien peut-être nous dit aujourd'hui
madame sama le juge d'instruction s'il y
apprécie stèle de grandes chances que
marie-france tatsu n'ai pas participé au
meurtre
rien n'est encore exclure l'instruction
en fait vient tout juste de commencer
par ailleurs le juge rappelle que
l'avocat n'a demandé la mise en liberté
de sa cliente que huit mois après le
début de l'instruction que marie-france
stade chaussée devant elle toujours
comportés de façon bizarre sans défense
logique et qu'enfin un land détention
provisoire n'a rien d'exceptionnel ce
serait le cas pour les trois quarts des
affaires criminelles
reste que si le non lieu est prononcé le
préjudice sera énorme pour marie-france
tâte saut un an de prison pour les uns
et pour les autres ça ne s'oublie pas
facilement tous les amateurs de planche
à voile ont dû suivre avec beaucoup
d'intérêt et peut-être même avec envie
l'exploit de frédéric beauchesne et
thierry caroni la traversée de
l'atlantique nord dans le sens amérique
europe
les deux français viennent d'arriver à
bon port mais complètement épuisé daniel
auclair mardi 20 heures le soleil se
couche sur le cap lizard au sud de
l'angleterre
c'est l'heure de la délivrance pour fred
beauchêne et thierry caroni
38 jours de traversée sur une planche à
voile c'est long trop long même depuis
une semaine les deux hommes étaient sans
nourriture ils ont terminé leur voyage
au bord de l'épuisement mécontents on va
chez le roi
ouais je suis tombé s'est pas fait point
sinon je tombais sur le panneau derrière
moi ça va
ça a été long 38 pour toujours c'est
psychologiquement c'est dur aussi parce
que
il ya trois mètres carrés à de la tente
pendant 40 jours il faut prendre sur soi
quelquefois mois ont été durs avec le
coéquipier bon on peut bien trop guerric
tamarins
on sait bien gueuler quelquefois mais ça
fait partie du jeu et on a su se
contrôler comme de vieux mais coup de
vieux [ __ ] quoi moi je la 7ème art 11e
traversée de l'atlantique à la voile
la première en planche je pense que ça
sera la dernière étape est sûre il y
avait un tirage du loto aujourd'hui
voici les résultats il fallait jouer les
7 14 17 37 38 49 et un numéro
complémentaire le 8
demain il y aura un quarter à enghien il
se disputera dans le prix de château
gontier sur les dix-huit partants
monsieur courtine a choisi et 16,2 1,5
c'est son joker prince à tous puis 11 13
et 9 la météo pour demain le temps sera
de plus en plus orageux ces orages
affecteront dès le matin les régions
proches de l'atlantique et l'ouest du
massif central
les perturbations gagneront ensuite une
grande partie de la france l'après midi
seules l'alsace la corse et l'extrême
sud est seront ensoleillé les
températures seront encore très élevé
dans quelques secondes tout de suite
après ce journal je vous invite à suivre
un document qui a été réalisé par le
centre national de prévention de la
délinquance
il s'agit d'une expérience originale qui
a pour cadre la ville de schiltigheim en
alsace ce film s'appelle enfants en
citoyens et il a été primé au dernier
festival du film d'entreprise à biarritz
demain nous nous retrouverons à 22
heures en attendant voici le rappel des
titres de ce journal très bonne fin de
soirée
afrique du nord le gouvernement français
en afrique du sud le gouvernement
français rappelle son ambassadeur et
suspend tous les nouveaux
investissements manifestations violentes
des sidérurgie du néo métal l'inquiétude
demeure malgré les assurances du
ministère de l'industrie
deux inculpés pour un même heure
paroisse en jeune femme a peut-être fait
un an de prison pour rien
et